so if this were the writer's room yeah
martyr would be pacing and Roselle would
be lying under the table yeah
writing paper shredding paper of some
sort like into time
lining a blood transfusion Glenn would
be drinking 100 raw egg yolks
yeah all right uh you sit down
makes great content I haven't seen that
one in a while no I know we're gonna
have to catch up feel free to like Pride
oh yeah we're gonna dig in we're gonna
get in some stuff I listened to one on
the way over here you did one of these
the gang sells out and so you're like oh
that's what it sounds like when Robin
Charlie and Glenn talk to one another
turn it off pretty quickly
I I have never listened to a single
podcast
ever cross anything I've never listened
why
what is because I'm rigid you are
missing out man on a lot of them what do
I have playing I don't know music I
don't well let me tell you something
it's not like I even lost I used to
listen to only Stern and I fell off of
that with pandemic like I don't know
just music
[Laughter]
but it's kind of like me with candy and
fruit and stuff like I've just decided
I'm not gonna dip into podcasts
which is the smart I hear like I'm
missing out because like if like
um you know if there's someone you
really are interested in and admire like
uh here's an example like I love Paul
Thomas Anderson I love his movies I
think he's a brilliant guy
there's some great like Marin sits and
talks with him for two hours here it's
great you
get the podcast you just get little bits
at the so you never really get into any
sort of quality part I work from home
all the time so I I feel like there's no
commute anywhere I've got no drive time
anymore that's true we got to get you
driving more I've been driven in a in
quite some time to a destination and
this was a nice change I did it get the
[__] out so you guys now are just oh
well let's go let's let's not let's go
let's start at the beginning let's start
at the beginning uh all right this is
the podcast where I'm glad have declined
to show up right not because of you guys
it would have been cool if you weren't
here either
[Laughter]
there's a rewrite that we owe on the
last season like
oh that's a complete trick they're
excited about us being on though right
yeah yeah they're really happy you're
here they're super happy
bummed to miss this
first so yeah so this is this I can I
can get behind that
where do I begin uh okay
well first of all how many seasons did
you guys write on It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
I think uh I think I was there for 13.
13. no 11 11. I was there for 11 Seasons
I'd have to calculate it I probably 11
10 or 11. because you okay you left for
a few seasons and I came on for a few
seasons so oftentimes they'll hear us
talking about martyr and Roselle uh so
uh on the podcast we have here for our
listeners at home uh Rob Rozelle and
Scott marter and uh you guys came out at
season three and I I would say made
um a huge impact on the show just in
terms of your tone of comedy and and
what you guys brought to the show it
really sort of changed the Direction and
the tone of the show made it so much
better and uh we held on to you for as
long as we possibly could until your
careers were just taking off and we
couldn't we couldn't pin you down
anymore but uh Ben got you back on the
down
older yeah in the last two seasons thank
God but uh
um
I want to go all the way back to the
beginning had you guys been staffed up
on a television show before you worked
with us or was ours your first show no
we had we'd only we've done one thing
right the camp movie that was American
Summer some sort of it only the American
Sky franchise we met with a guy who had
he had I'm no joke five cell phones on a
table when we met him at the Grand
Havana room yes
when we met him he was at a table with
all of his medication on the table as if
he had dumped his medicine cabinet on
the table and he's like sorry baby I'm
trying to regulate my pills like what a
crazy red flag we still ignored that got
into business with him then it was a
nightmare
he would call it all hours of the day
like he'd call it 4 P.M I love it baby I
love what you're doing he called 4am I'm
terrified I think the movie's going
under like they're like God damn it did
he pay you guys very little it broke
down to like a nickel an hour I mean
yeah so he sort of had drummed up his
own kind of he had
won't say his name but he was a
successful producer who had made a few
hits yeah so it seemed really big time
so he seemed legitimate he seemed
legitimate the cigar bar was a red flag
being paid sort of like out of his
pocket was a bit of a red flag no one
really asking for the it was unclear
what the plan for the movie was but he
seemed to have a plan and we didn't know
anything and we didn't have jobs so
wait can I back up even further so you
guys were a writing team when you
started see I always thought you just
were paired up on sunny but you came in
yeah we went to Syracuse together oh I
didn't know we came out to LA ready to
ride we were roommates
too funny guys uh who went to Syracuse
uh came to La got teamed up with a man
full of pills and cell phones
uh yeah and wrote a feature for this man
was it a feature it was it was okay it
was a feature
um so now a good example of the way the
impact you guys had on the show is even
you telling me that story right now we
would be like okay right we have to do
something where Frank is pitching
someone a thing and he's got five cell
phones on the table and a pile of pills
like just the
very sort of
idiosyncratic sense of humor and the way
you guys look at the world changed what
we were doing so we started doing things
like rum hams and milk steaks but but
before we get into that okay so you've
done that and it had gone over
it overlapped with our first season it's
sunny we had an agent who was sending us
out we would meet on shows we were just
like we would have worked on anything
but uh no one wanted to hire us and we
got a lot of maybe next season and then
Sonny popped up as a our agent told us
that they were we were taking a swing
that long I mean we wrote we wrote a
Golden Girls spec it just creates more
drama we
we were one day away from being broke we
shared a bank account like Ben and Matt
oh yeah well you said like you said we
wrote this Golden Girl spec that was
called Golden Girls Gone Wild that was
like a crazy episode and it got a lot
really positive response and we were
feeling like the momentum of like we're
gonna get staff soon and then Sonny
popped up we're like that's our favorite
show this is the perfect spec for it
um we sent it to you guys and you guys
didn't like it
I don't even remember reading The Golden
Girls back but do you remember what
Barry said he did and that's what her
agent claimed he did because you guys
were like yeah it's too crazy so Barry
claims our agent back in the day a claim
that he tore the page off of another
sample we had and it was like if you
don't like those guys check out these
guys and you're like these guys got this
stuff and it was a Reno 911 we had
written and that got us Sonny unlikely
you know I I I well here's what I do
remember so that that this was our first
season hiring writers we've done season
one and we've done season two we were
going into season three and in season
two uh Hornsby wrote an episode but
outside of that uh we we worked with
another guy named um I think his name
was rich Dom who wrote an episode
but we ended up not using it and uh
so this was our first time Staffing up
we didn't really know how to do it so we
were just meeting people maybe we were
reading spec scrubs but I think it was
more okay who do the agents think we
should meet with uh from all sorts of
levels like high level guys and and
Young Writers uh you know men and women
all over this the spectrum of of uh
where they're at with their career
and we had asked for people to pitch us
potential episodes of sunny and you guys
came in and you pitched us the thing
about Frank being in a street gang
called the yellow jackets with a bunch
of old guys well I have an addendum to
that because I just listened to the gang
cells out on the way over here the
yellow jackets and hockey hockey was
martyr's Dad yeah oh yeah he was in he
was in the yellow jackets gang right uh
he was the fastest thing on two feet
that's why everyone called him hockey
the actor was your father no the actor
was based on my father oh okay yeah so I
think you guys came in you pitched us
that which we thought was hilarious you
probably told us stories about your
father and we were like these two guys
are brilliant maybe I remember reading
in Reno 9-1-1 but it was it was it
it never really had much to do with the
spec script it usually had to do with do
we feel like we're gonna get funny ideas
from these guys do they get what we're
trying to make you know sometimes people
will come oftentimes they would pitch us
things and they were all just about like
STDs and gets herpes we were we were
warned to not do that going and like
doing pitch them STD stuff yeah we were
like 11th Hour like hey hey hey no sex
no sex you're like that's definitely
like five ideas yeah well I think people
were were
they were thinking it was just a gross
out show yes and so they were pitching
like bottom of the barrel kind of gross
out of humor and we didn't want that we
wanted something like yeah Danny used to
be in a street gang and like and that
they street gangs used to sing and uh
the humor in that so I remember yeah I
remember it was a no-brainer to hire you
guys do you guys remember your interview
with them I remember I remember it yeah
I don't remember all of the ideas we
pitched we definitely we definitely
pitched the flipping flipping the coke
that was when we pitched on that first
day that became an episode oh yeah yeah
two or three of the ones we pitched in
our interview became episodes
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know what
oh yeah yeah then we had this crappy
crappy building and
uh we're Manhattan Beach
Del Rey right it was like middle
industrial Warehouse that looked like
you would if you wanted a set for like a
gang fight you would do it it was on a
street called Beatrix I think oh yeah
wow I remember pulling in and seeing
like a pickup truck
a little Audi and a really old Lexus and
being like I wonder which who's yeah
yeah yeah so I had that Audi then all
right cool and then that was that was
the first time we had an office
so I don't know if you guys thought you
were coming into like a thing that was
more of like this is a show and we but
like none of like Rob Gwen and I we
didn't know what we were doing either
still you know we just had kind of spit
out two seasons somehow this is our
first time even having an office
building we didn't know if we should
have computers and it was our first time
having a staff do you remember who else
was on that staff well David Hornsby
would have been right for sure
that was Adam Stein was the writer's
assistant Adam Stein was a writer system
he got a couple good jokes in that
season he do he um go for some wood I
remember that first I remember that
first day uh we were writer's assistants
so we were used to being in rooms but we
were like so what's the menu for today
like what's the lunch I'm not gonna say
what do you mean lunch we're like
we're like you don't get free lunch and
immaculating like stormed down the hall
that was not gonna hear him barking at
someone on FX and came back he's like we
got free lunch now what else are we
supposed to be getting that we never got
before okay so wait so you had been
writer's assistants in a room oh yeah
yeah we we had been both been writer's
assistants on various shows okay so you
had some experience yeah so we were kind
of looking to you guys a little bit to
be like what is a writer's room do and
we were very much from like network
shows that were like so different than
the house yeah we would function at its
best okay okay so this is interesting so
you had had the experience of being
going to like the lot and going into
like a nice building and everyone's got
like a computer that's got a computer
yeah there's a lot of like uh just
things that you just expect to be there
like your your computer your office the
lunch uh the lunch macaloney's reaction
to the lunch was our first exposure to
Rob mcelhensive
I'm thinking I'm remembering now that we
learn from you guys that the studio was
supposed to supply computers to the
writers yes stuff like that we
definitely like brought to the table so
we got on our line producer about like
Hey we're supposed to have computers and
that was when I got my first computer
yeah I think like Sunny almost didn't
exist really but the three of you had
really put computers that were like can
I I was can I see scripts from season
one you're like I don't know if I'm able
to find those yeah everyone's like
digging through like broken computers to
find scripts and stuff I remember at my
desk I did have some sort of desk but it
was makeshift and we made a milk in a
room filled with chairs it was awesome
an office in a facility that was like
manufacturing things sometimes it was
like very much not an office uh but I
the script or part of the script for Mac
bangs Dennis's mom was on like a yellow
notepad scribbled out oh yeah yeah and
should have kept it I have I have a few
notepads from
uh I have the gang lost an abortion or
whatever that the abortion episode I
have the legal pad still no that's cool
notes on that which is fun were you guys
tempted to tell them extra things that
you used to get just to see like we get
cars and like uh we're so nervous yeah
I'm not bold like that at all so nervous
yeah what were you nervous about nervous
that like Rob Glenn and I would be like
oh we don't like these guys writing or
their jokes or that you wouldn't like us
I thought this was like the greatest
show like getting this job was like
winning the lottery I mean when I saw
Mac bangs Dennis's mom like our agent
gave it to us on like DVD or something
yeah I remember watching it and then
just watching it like over and over and
over I just I still think it's like the
best episode a little bit weird with
what he was watching but that was that
that was the episode that got me too
really yeah it like kind of unlocked the
show for me well yeah it's one of my
favorites for sure uh so I mean then
that third season we had to do 15 I know
episodes was the most we ever did did
yeah I don't know how costume Department
it was a lot very busy that year yeah
sure because we were kind of taking some
bigger broader swings that season and
then like it's been interesting watching
them back because the fourth season we
start to find something and the fifth
season we really hit our stride in terms
of the tone I agree all right well let's
let's get into a little bit more about
the two of you guys first of all your
dad speaking of hockey you would tell us
so many stories about your dad and and I
I ran into you at a party and you told
me a story about your dad eating this
canned meat which I was saying it it
wound up not working his way into this
into Sunday the season but there's so
many stories about your dad would find
their way into like stories about Frank
um for sure they line up they they line
up really close to each other and Mack
right shooting himself in the belly with
the insulin yep
the story about the canned meat my dad
uh was really thrilled by this beef stew
that he got at the flea market and he
was digging into it and had a couple
cans of it and my mom saw how much he
enjoyed it so she opened one up to have
for dinner and then till she turned
around and saw that it was dog food that
he had been eating uh
um
food I guess it was dog food I didn't
remember it was dog food so like you
know you see that little meager food
section at like an Exxon like that type
of food you know you could buy food at a
flea market who's ever done that I mean
my father like I'll buy anything at the
flea market and this is how a story
starts he's like because then we're like
okay great so like Frank
really wants to get the game to go out
of the flea market because that's where
you get the best meat yeah you know and
then they realize that they're then we'd
be like okay then maybe they're like
they realize it's dog food but then
they're like what else does a dog do
that I'm missing out on connection with
you market and dog food there's some
conspiracy here yeah it's so conspiracy
I think you can all agree it tastes good
right so if we're willing to look past
who it's intended for yeah I'll keep
eating it what is your dad eating now
let's see same stuff same stuff I mean
my dad's like live action Homer Simpson
he just eats such garbage like sleeves
of Oreos right before bed like Mountain
Dew all day it doesn't drink water he
doesn't like the taste of it all he
drinks is soda which is he's 80. I mean
to make it to 80 and all you drink is
soda it's pretty remarkable that's
pretty aggressive yeah don't stop now
and the room he showed us a funny
picture of your dad in bed like
surrounded by what was that he was like
covered up
um he sleeps like a vampire I do too so
I can't throw stones but I was not gonna
bring it up
over a pillow
pillows right pillow over face I sleep
with my head between two pillows like a
taco cover cover over me completely
entombed and now one of my sons does
that too so it's now generational yeah
wow so then you feel contained and hot
packed in yeah like a sardine well you
have one story about temping and having
a little bit of a stomach issue oh yes
which is one of my favorite you know
we've told the story about the the poor
young man who auditioned for the show
and had horrible diarrhea and then went
behind the dumpster to wipe his own butt
with his own headshots it was just I
didn't hear I've never yeah it's it's
his first ever audition and he realizes
he's gonna have diarrhea and someone's
in the in the bathroom and he can hear
them running their lines and it's taking
forever and he goes behind the dumpster
and he shits in his pants and he's
trying to clean it up with his own
headshots and he gives up and he throws
his pants
out his window driving home because they
smell so bad and he rear-ends somebody
um Batman was James Marston
it's my favorite poop story of all time
uh second is your temping story I was
temping at my dad's insurance company in
New York and was wearing a dress shirt
that was way too big uh and when I went
to use the bathroom probably after lunch
uh I didn't realize that once I sat down
on the toilet that the shirt was so big
that it had created a hammock that
completely didn't allow anything to
reach the water so when I finished
pooping I looked down and saw my dress
shirt was just perfectly cradling a [__]
uh which was a real situation because I
was in New York I live in New Jersey I
didn't have like a different pair of
clothing stores he went and bought a new
shirt right that would have been the
sport thing to do no I took off my shirt
and was probably just bare chested just
scrubbing poop out of my eyes shirt and
then wore it for the rest of the day I
remember you telling me that you took
off your shirt and then you gave up and
you walked shirtless through the office
and you said that you quit but I didn't
quit no but I definitely wore it the
rest of the day and probably should have
been fired uh okay oh my God that is
that is a great story that is a good one
well I've got some questions for you
guys but
um but just to say a little thing about
Scott is that um Scott is responsible
for me ending up on the show because I
met Scott first before I met any OU's
really yeah because
um I hired Scott onto a failed project
of mine that I was developing for FX and
he was great and I believe the first
time we met I cried at our first meeting
we were we met like at a bar or
something I'm like yeah another drink I
I ordered a drink and then I cried in
front of him at our first meeting
because it was a bad development
situation and I was just but he was so
nice about it and I was like this is the
sort of person that I need because I
needed like a number two so I hired uh I
hired Scott on and then he was great and
um but the project like died and then I
probably because I spent most of the
time talking to you about how much I
love sunny and how you you're
responsible for most of my favorite
episodes including the game gives Frank
Intervention which we just talked about
which is my number one face one of my
favorites too yeah it's very strong yeah
I just watched everybody holds up and
that's where night crawlers came in for
the first time which you guys are
responsible before that's right you got
you guys are responsible for the lyrics
for Damon yeah that was the first one of
the first things we ever wrote and that
was the first group he wrote for the
show it was the first script and I
remember the day man we one of the
things that was unique about Sonny was
how little you had on
breaks sometimes like sometimes you guys
would see it but it wouldn't be the
amount of information that the writer
would have would there be a lot less the
flip side to that is there's a lot of
freedom and you could fix things and
sort of experiment it became something I
grew to really love you you hated it uh
but uh you like a more detailed outline
a little bit more anal I don't remember
what we had for that it was like did
they sing us they sing day man and then
we just wrote the lyrics kind of quickly
assuming we would like rewrite them or
something yeah and then it just that
remained yeah it came together real
quick yeah why fighter of the night man
Champion where'd all that come from
karate and all that I don't know we just
like wrote it out it was very short and
then it uh caught on somehow just wrote
out master of karate and friendship well
yeah I don't know where that came from
randomly um
actually I wanted to go through with you
guys do a sort of lightning round which
I'm going to call are you responsible
for this which are things that have been
claimed on this podcast that maybe you
guys have are responsible straight okay
the melting dog in the alley from sweet
D gets audited that one's you Roselle
that's based on your dad's story yeah
yes my dad uh
he was he worked with the for this guy
who had a this big house and all these
dogs and my dad uh I won't get into the
specifics of his job it was a real
estate thing but sometimes he'd be over
at this house kind of like helping them
with whatever they were doing and he was
watching their dogs while they were away
and one day he went over to feed the
dogs and one dog was dead so he dug a
hole and you know give the dog a burial
and I guess had been out in the sun for
so long that he said oh my God he said
that when they put the dog
they had to pick the dog up with a
bucket and because it was so souped up
it was settled soupy and loose from the
Heat and he poured it in to a hole and
it was like pouring in like a like a
noodle soup or something
yeah and that uh that stuck in my brain
and yeah yeah I remember you pitched
that and everyone's like yes dog soup
of course okay the dick flyer from
Denison D's mom is dead I I didn't pitch
the dick flower that it looks like a
bicep wasn't you guys we were there for
it I don't remember being uh Hornsby
wrote the script for that
I don't remember how I remember
definitely being there for that I
remember us sketching it on paper
together like uh
it may have been Hornsby or you guys I
would say yeah all right night crawlers
I don't remember that feels very much
like a nightcrawlers
yeah they crawl around like worms in the
night yeah um Frank's doo-wop group
we've already established uh my dad was
in a group my dad's actual group name
was called Vito and the salutations
when she got kicked out of he got booted
out of video yeah they didn't they
didn't think he had the stuff now did
your dad sing as a part of that group he
tried I would love to yeah they have an
album I think you can find their album
Vito and the salutation yeah he's not on
it though right no but would they also
kind of run the streets in their leather
he said he separately was in that sort
of squad there used to be a club called
the one two three club and my Dad loved
the one two three Club because you could
go in there and you could walk in Kick
the Jukebox and one two three you're in
a fight what's that what you would
always say
and that was the best part of the one
two three you're in a fight I was
expecting them to go he liked it yeah a
singing fight because the Jukebox
alley fight yeah the Rococo bang did you
guys come up with that the gang dances
their asses off I guarantee Rococo came
from us because that's just like a yes
like a play on a word that we found
Dennis does the Rococo bang with the
um with the woman and the Gang dances
their asses off yeah and then like drops
her right he's like I think that was a
challenging episode dances the rest off
from that same episode karate snow
machine chops it which Charlie has
attributed to to you guys I think you
guys wrote that lyric that line I was
like that is I think so I was really
[__] up on the pills and he's the
whole writing experience is a fever
dream because I remember we were we
didn't have a lot of time what we had to
go on was the Jane Fonda movie They
Shoot Horses Don't They you know that
classic
yeah yeah and I think it was Rob who was
like we did we want to do this like you
guys I think are maybe already in
production or something it was like this
do an episode based on this and we three
watched them like oh yeah it was tough
to see but we ended up staying up like
three days and in those little offices
at one point someone walked into our
kitchen and we were like who is that it
was Lisa Bonet and I don't know where
she was going uh I remember that
building in that building I remember we
also wrote a piece of it at hornsby's
like original apartment where he had
that neighbor that would bathe in the
garbage pail yes oh I was there for that
so uh you know David and I uh we had
these really good friends uh signed
Genevieve who lived right next door to
David and um
Psy was at the Williamstown theater
Festival with David and I and they had
like a little bit of rooftop on this
apartment building in on
on just off of Melrose and so we're
having like dinner out there like they
they they're fancy they would put
together a nice dinner for us they
invited David over Mary Elizabeth and I
were there
and we uh we hear from downstairs like
ah you guys you wanna go for a swim
and like and like what and we're like
look over the side of the roof let's
think of one-story buildings and not
like a hybrid and their neighbor is
standing in in his garbage can which
he's filled with water he's he's just
wasted and he's like he's like come on
this pool's great and it was like
they're like we're so sorry about him
and and he just had filled his garbage
can and sort of you know I can't believe
no one ever thought about this can't
believe people aren't doing this
anyways I remember that uh in Mac's big
break when they come when Dennis and Dee
are having a podcast
um Cricket wanting a rotisserie chicken
and getting lemons instead is that you
guys
100 what is it about rotisserie chickens
I know it's funny
yeah I can't explain it but I do find a
funny milk steak was that you guys or
was it as I remember it was like did
someone Miss hear someone in the room
well I think I pitched milk steak you
pitched milk steak that's pretty funny
but why where I mean now we're getting
into like that we need to dig it's
getting real deep down why yes why I
don't know I'm so anal that I bet I
could find why I feel like I have
everything that we ever did he has all
the records you have all the records I
held on everything impeccable records I
have every season labeled by season with
everything that we've ever did for
everyone I will still hit him up once in
a blue moon like do you have this script
because I have no records and like you
asked me about the gal style thing I
didn't remember it but I was able to
access my stuff because I'm not quite
Robin yeah not quite right robin never
made it to the screen you guys pitch
Gail the snail was that I think that was
Collective brainstorming for that sure
um how about the lyrics to the Frank's
little Beauties song the Magics in the
air
that was based on uh a real song Right
wasn't there a
and the guy sang a song about like magic
and light and yes that mortician
character was really funny oh my God
like this there's certain things too
where you just don't know you're like
uh you're like we're gonna have a
mortician and he's gonna do Frank's
makeup and you just don't know until you
see Danny come out looking like that how
funny it's gonna be like you just don't
know okay so you wrote who pooped the
bed did you come up with the stuff that
they found in the poop the like wolf
hair and credit cards wolf hair is
certainly signature martyr Roselle I
feel like Glenn came up with wolf hair
in the room
I remember flashes of things so did you
bring that idea in the who pooped the
pen I think so I don't remember you guys
came in like a like hot off the press I
feel like with like this idea it might
have been well we talked about how
Charlie wrote out the monologue at the
end like on the board very everything
inspiration right and then just goes on
a tear when someone when that's
happening you sort of stay out of their
way yeah right just like let them go it
happens to everybody but well that
brings up the next possibly most famous
monologue from Sunny which is the Pepe
Silvia monologue yep did you guys wrote
that we wrote We definitely wrote the we
did you guys did a pass at some point
but uh we wrote it I can't remember what
I pulled Pepe Sylvia from but I pulled
it from things I feel like on a board in
my bedroom similarly I was like Pepe
Sylvia right the guys were saying that
it was Silva and I was mispronouncing it
Silva Silva and I kept saying Sylvia
which was funnier
it's poor reading on my part but
and often people will say was he trying
to say Pennsylvania but that's not what
it was right it was just too funny it
was just a funny name funny name oh yeah
yeah no it's just a funny name yeah you
guys nailed that monologue I remember
like
just being like oh this is gonna be so
fun to do
and then part of the success of that too
is what Matt Chapman did from a
directing standpoint where he'd built
these things where the letters were just
dropping down constantly so we had
someone on a ladder dropping ladders
it's so funny man yeah he's a good
director it's a shame does he still work
unfortunately he does stuff that nobody
really cares about you know superheroes
and dragons and Game of Thrones
everything Game of Thrones and Marvel
and
um how about from the night man cometh
boys hole and boys Soul where you guys I
think that was me I gotta say I think
that was yeah I think yeah I feel like
you guys really took off with that one
soul
I got this one guys I'll take it well we
talked about how um from the gang hits
the road the whole thing about Charlie
having never eaten a pair was based on
Martyr never eating blueberries or
something I never had any fruit I had
never had any fruit and I never had any
candy bar growing up so that season
lunch every day the tree did not have a
candy bar just didn't have a sweet tooth
my parents eat everything so you were
allowed to have them you were just like
no I don't no thanks all I ate was salad
that's a strange person so weird strange
person wait a second have you since had
a blueberry and I have had a blueberry I
filled in Fruit I'd say there's I like
them yeah
[Music]
hey Megan guess what this show is
sponsored by better help oh betterhelp
is online therapy service designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule yeah that's right it's so easy
to get uh caught up in what everyone
else needs from you that it it's easy to
forget what you need for yourself right
yeah very true better helps licensed
professionals can give you the tools to
find that balance so that you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind therapy is for everyone
right so if you're on the fence about
trying it you know Now's the Time give
it a whirl yeah even Tony Soprano he
went to therapy he did he turned out
great
yeah Tony Soprano went fellas right so
there's no excuses here yeah men would
literally rather watch other men go to
therapy than go themselves sometimes
yeah but you know if the head of a Mafia
Family can find time and what I'm sure
is a very busy schedule uh you at home
probably can do it too right what do you
think would have happened if Tony
Soprano had better help well uh you know
it would have been easier for him to
find time in his uh busy schedule for
Juan he probably would have saved a
little bit of dough that's good number
two and then he just might just like
chilled out a little bit and you know
maybe picked a different direction for
his life which could have been good not
good for the show though would have been
much more boring of a show yeah a more
boring show but but a better life for
him yeah look everyone can find help
with better help that's the point right
visit betterhelp.com Sunny for 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com sunny
[Music]
this year was really fun to be in the
room with both of you and to see your
little like quirks like truly martyr
just Paces the entire time you're like
laying on the floor this year you got
into a whole thing where you were
creating Telemundo shows for David
destarin
yes I was drawing things and with
starring David Hornsby
Telemundo shows that were all in Spanish
and you might work the best if I'm not
working on what I'm supposed to be
working on and then I'll be able to like
pitch more things I don't know really
yeah if you're if you're thinking about
something completely different try to
like low level distract myself it's all
it's a there's a method to oh sure yeah
there's a better thought out now so okay
so that that first season you guys wrote
with us we're out in Playa del Rey we
get through it uh uh it all comes
together you're happy with what happens
and then we call you up and we say hey
good news we got picked up for another
season I remember probably season by
season at that point first feedback that
I had gotten
uh that made me relax a little bit I
didn't tell you about it uh was
mcelhoney called me I remember I was in
h m buying like Christmas presents and
we had just handed in our first script
like a week before and Michael and he
called me to say how much you guys had
loved it and I remember big weight being
lifted that was that was sort of a
pivotal moment and uh the emotional
trajectory and then we just started
writing we wrote a lot of the episodes
in season three and clearly yeah
we got we had a good thing going on
creatively all of us so I we worked on
another show in between the first season
or the third season in the fourth season
really the cavemen show um
one of the worst shows of all time on
television based off the ad but then A
call came down from the president of ABC
like early into pre-production being
like it can't be anything like the
commercials which was a weird a weird
thing
but make sure you don't reference them
at all so no cable no keep the caveman
all right okay so then uh so we finished
that that third season you guys go to
the cavemen you get staffed on caveman
yeah and that coincided with the writer
strike too and then the writer strike
and then there was a strike yeah what
was the experience going from Sunny to
Cayman like from our you know Warehouse
in a off on a shady road to back to a
network thing I mean I don't think any
part of uh I I no part of me liked
anything better about being on cavemen
than sunny and like even though it was I
don't know it was on the Sony lot in the
data offices and whatnot we had such a
good thing going on at Sunny yeah I was
just we just needed to make money I just
remember it
just it being hard to write other stuff
because I just I felt like I wanted to
write more Sunny because we've really
got in the groove so we met love Rocky
there exactly right yeah
he came in I want to say he came in five
maybe five I think yeah yeah that's
right influential Sunny writer yeah um I
have found that
for my two cents the the most rewarding
part of this business this career is
getting a group of people that you click
with creatively and making something in
a bubble sort of outside the result of
it outside there obviously is very nice
when it reaches people and and and
people have a nice reaction to it but
for
that's completely out of our control so
the best part of the experience for me
is finding something that we're all dug
in on that we don't know how to do it so
the early seasons of Sunday where we
don't know what it even an episode of
something really is still
is the most rewarding part of of this
experience I I
I'm sad we can't ever go back to that
place with this show I agree that we
can't ever just be like in a little
bubble yeah because we were just making
ourselves laugh like nothing was more
rewarding than like we'd be cracking
ourselves up and then it would hit the
airwaves then people would feel the same
like what what's more what's a better
gift than that I mean it's awesome yeah
and we can do a different thing and it's
still and having you guys there this
year was great and I think the episodes
are really good this year as a result
but um never that we can never be as
lost as we were and there's something
really amazing about that so even going
into season four we still don't totally
know like what an episode of the show is
uh but now we're in a different
Warehouse we're in Culver City so we've
moved a little more moved warehouses it
was a slightly nicer warehouse but still
pretty crappy now we're a team right now
we're like all right we did this thing
we're feeling good about it it was a
good season had some new writers had
some new writers well I think a funny
thing in season four was that you guys
felt like Rob and I worked out so well
that when we came back for season four
there were three other writing teams you
guys like this writing team thing is
so it was the biggest room the show had
ever had we came back and it was like
Jordan Elijah Becky and Audra Pat and
sunny like the room was huge I forgot
because you got because you guys were
like writing writing teams that's the
bang for them like Sunny Lee and Pat
Walsh for a team oh yeah yes
that's right and they were a good team
they were fun had that super funny thing
with Pat with uh he was pitching
something and I don't did you do it I I
did it he was wearing a hoodie and he
was pitching something and Roselle just
reached over and unzipped the hoodie and
we saw that he wasn't wearing a shirt he
was just wearing a hoodie and he was
suddenly just bare chested and
completely deflated the pitch and
everyone's like who wears just a hoodie
man not on like Glenn with the cereal in
the car dug in that there was nothing
weird about wearing a zip up Hoodie
maybe he crapped in his shirt right
[Laughter]
um
why is this weird it's just it don't
wear a zipper with no fabric underneath
of it yeah that derailed the room for
like an hour
like you came to a writer's room where
not a nice crowd like you know yeah do
something you're gonna get picked apart
I think something that is important for
the audience to know is that
it's such a group effort writing a
television series that you know
just because you guys are credited for
certain episodes doesn't mean you're not
writing on all the episodes and it
doesn't mean we wrote the episodes
before and I lose track like I could I I
have good memories of writing the ones
we like really had to dig in on but like
a lot of the other ones are cloudy
because I remember bits and pieces of us
and all of them yeah yeah and the more
people that you have in the room that
are really contributing the better the
show becomes because I think around that
season four season five season six we
had to really we were in sync everyone
was in sync and and different people
were providing different sort of
perspectives that were all sort of
gelling into the show and you know the
the difference is I think was for us for
who sort of stayed how much someone
contributes and then how much their sort
of stamp goes on the show and um
and then their ability to execute
something if we're not there you know
which you guys and Hornsby really had
down Meg you when you came on uh you
know you had that Talent as well or
could run the room or sort of push story
forward yeah I was jealous though
because uh of these guys because um
rob you he talks about you guys like the
funniest people that I've ever worked
you know for the best writers I've ever
worked with and I'm always sitting there
like well
but it is like specifically I think
what's so amazing is you guys just like
I would never in a million years be able
to think of like boiled denims you know
denims I know are you guys it's just a
weird particular thing that is just like
like uh or Charlie's dreams I think
maybe you guys did that with the denim
chickens and like the weird yeah like I
can't think that way the rats it's a
weird one yeah my brain will not did you
guys come up with uh can I offer you a
nice egg in this trying time 100 yeah
I've been poisoned by my constituents
like that whole thing is the specificity
of stuff like that I just like uh yeah
my mine is my contributions are mostly
good handwriting for the dry erase board
not true at all
I feel like we I Feel Like That season
actually started and we didn't bring
anyone new on and we felt like we needed
to shake it up so everyone's like who do
you got and I was like Gans we gotta get
her over I feel like that particular
season we didn't even read specs maybe I
even met with you I feel like you came
in no I'm I'm out with you in Hornsby
okay because I was just like we just get
her in here yeah um but but that season
worked out great like that that influx
of energy like yeah that was a great
season yeah um yeah it's the better the
energy is in that room the better the
season is there's no doubt about it
season five was certainly a high water
mark of just us all being feeling
confident in what we were doing yeah in
a flow I think everybody I think we had
sort of figured out what makes the show
work
uh but didn't know it so well that you
know we were boxed into the structure or
anything one of the episodes that you
wrote in season five was the Dennis
system which is such an amazing also one
of my favorites yeah it was just how do
you remember like how that came up and
like that he had a system and I it was
off of that book the game being a thing
oh okay yeah which our roommate was
obsessed with yeah that's a whole other
podcast
all right so you had to run away who was
obsessed with the game learning the game
trying to studying it like uh studying
it like you would read it like an
automotive manual methods for picking up
women yes for tricking women was a big
thing yeah
Ulta woman yeah your breath stinks
peacocking was the thing if you wear a
ridiculous like purple hat I have to say
I was I was living in New York and
heavily dating during this time and had
the effect of the game I feel presented
upon music specifically my buddy would
wear a tie like a bandana
like wear just a time did the game work
on you never because it was just awkward
and it was like always yeah go for it it
was um it was always he's nagging me
right now by using the best Charlie this
is really good use of the game did it
ever work for your friend did he ever
bring home women like confused and uh
you know
nothing nefarious uh I don't think it it
worked for him when you're so clearly
adhering to A system that can be uh
off-putting to a woman
like hey flosser no floss you don't like
being asked that as an opening cell
phone yeah
so odd and uh but so you were like oh
well what if somebody had a very that
was like we kind of started talking
about that in season four I remember and
it may have even gotten written on the
board where we were definitely remember
it being written on the Board Room
riffing kind of like oh this could be a
thing the Dennis system what would that
be and the putting the letters up I
think we had the words and that held
what is it an acronym yeah an acronym
yeah an acronym I feel like we had that
acronym the previous season and then we
finally wrote it yes we didn't do it for
whatever reason and then we explored it
the next season and it just came
together in that one yeah it's just such
a great episode and um that started
started also Manta
uh R.I.P Gladys and uh what other ones
oh the gang wrestles for the troops was
in that episode and jean shorts like the
jean shorts did the splits thing with
jean shorts uh that became like a
something that was referenced often we
had a gene short Obsession yes weird I
still find it fascinating like I saw a
guy the other day biking down the street
in those like jean shorts that get like
stop at the knee and thinking what an
uncomfortable why not wear another bike
riding like wear a different don't wear
regular shorts like the jean shorts they
kind of look funny and they're not
really comfortable and they're hotter
than a normal short yeah it was like we
jammed a lot in that one yeah that's
right Desert Rose oh yes
um birds of war and that one as well the
birds of War song yeah yeah birds of War
I remember you guys pitching though a
bucket of chestnuts and being like Ah
that's so funny he's got chestnuts and
then and then us being trying to decide
like how did he get is he foraging for
them like what you know and then
something that uh Roddy Roddy did in
that episode which I remember trying to
pitch him on the day was uh
the drifting off when we ask him if he's
got kids oh yeah and he stops and he
drifts off and he looks in space he goes
nah not no more
guys like you you know what I love you
guys man you know you you remind me of
my kids oh you got kids maniac
nah not anymore
what does that mean
well that so the gang wrestles troops
has lots of big ideas but some of my
favorite Sunny episodes are like really
small ideas like mac and Dennis breakup
which is such a like simple small story
um about them feeling like they've
gotten into a rut and they need to go
but also as coupled with the cat in the
wall story uh does that come from you
guys do you remember where that idea
came from you may have pitched the cat
in the wall in the room uh I don't know
I don't recall who came up with smoke
some cigarettes they'll they'll snuff
out the apple seeds or I think I did
yeah not being allowed to eat the
cigarettes are another running thing
like weird uses of cigarettes that
episode I love and like you guys are
such great actors together and when
sometimes when you get out of the way
and just let it be a small scene but and
we're I find we would often be striving
for things like that but the reality is
like you just can't do too many of them
you need both right
special for the troops and then you need
those guys trying to get me on a dating
website yeah and if it's all one or the
other the show gets dull I mean that's
the other thing you're always trying to
surprise the audience right the so much
of Comedy is just dropping something
that no one expects and that's what's so
great about you guys is you're sort of
idiosyncratic sense of humor that's so
unpredictable and these terms and ideas
that you thought up that no one's
thought of before like things like milk
steak we're like well what is that uh
but then that finding that balance and
then trying to maintain it throughout a
season is so definitely tricky I mean
what I loved about this show was it felt
like it was always doing things that you
couldn't do on other things so when
someone would throw out the idea of like
a baby funeral like we have to strive
yeah yeah like because you're not going
to see that on anything else but we have
the ability to do that so we gotta try
to stick it in that sweet spot too of
like coming from starting at a time
where television was pretty controlled
by you know network television where you
only are allowed to do a certain type of
humor because trying to reach the
broadest audience possible yeah now
there's so much television there's so
much content content that uh you know it
makes Sonny less unique in that regard
of like uh the extremes that we were
going to but at the time you know we
were kind of really getting away with
something that a lot of shows weren't
that was the craziest thing now that you
say that about Sonny and you asked like
kind of the difference between rooms the
it was shocking how little constrictions
we had other than our the ones that we
wanted to put on ourselves and that we
could really come whatever we kind of
came up with could be on television and
that that was so unique it was yeah
because it was very cool about you guys
that like we could write something I
could make it to air because like 99 of
most shows get Rewritten a million times
over from the writer's draft to blah
blah but if you guys found something
funny you let it live which was cool I'm
always amazed at stuff that works and
stuff that doesn't work and it's just
not what you think you kind of you have
to just it's a process that is
continually evolving so the idea that
there is like finite answers at the an
early stage of it as just the script
before it's performed and blah blah blah
a great script isn't a guaranteed great
episode yeah yeah and vice versa but
it's a good start
yeah yeah I mean it's so much harder to
make a bad script oh you know uh work
and then clean it up in the editing room
versus something that on the page
beginning to end is really singing and
you're like ah this one just came
together but you're right it's very
unpredictable what is and isn't a good
script uh of Sunny specifically I can't
I'm not speaking to other shows I can't
sure I can't speak to that but like of
Sunny when you write something you're
like well it just it seems like this one
should work and then you get in the
editing room and you're like we gotta we
gotta come up with something to yeah
like this storyline doesn't work and we
have to take that out of the episode now
or like and sometimes it's
um
you know the way something's been filmed
sometimes it's it's the music we've
chosen
um a good example was uh two episodes
that just did not work at all until the
editing room were um the suburbs episode
uh and uh and the Gang dines out which
we had to just come up with two great
ones yeah different musical sort of
theme the suburbs one we went sort of
with the shining and played it dark
versus what was originally in there
which was like Sunny music sort of
transitioning and it just didn't work at
all and then um
and same with the sort of Italian theme
that we have playing in that uh for
whatever reason yeah it is like a
Godfather feel or something it needed
that
so it's yeah the whole process beginning
to end it's pretty crazy
[Music]
sorry
sponsored by viori A New Perspective on
performance apparel inspired by the
active Coastal California lifestyle I
love I love love love love love fiori
it's amazing I do have a question oh
maybe your question is about how they're
so well made and flattering yet
comfortable um so you want to change out
of whatever you're wearing right then
and straight into the viore no no I'm
not unclear about that that's all
perfectly clear to me and now that you
are reminding me I'm going to change
into my viewers as soon as this podcast
is over and get a little more
comfortable
um maybe your questions about how
they're offsetting a hundred percent of
their carbon footprint and 100 of their
plastic footprint from 2019 and Beyond
no I I was not wondering about that but
is that for real because now I am that's
that's amazing yeah so what was your
question then why is it pronounced viori
yeah because like look at the letters
like where the Ori I'm not seeing an e
in there at all you know I'm seeing lots
of other vowels but so what are they
getting the e sound this is a v u yeah
apparently it means a mountain in
Finnish are you finished
um well fiori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they're
offering 20 off your first purchase so
get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet at viori.com Sunny pod that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny pod yeah not
only are you going to receive 20 off of
your first purchase but you're gonna
enjoy free shipping on any us orders uh
over 75 bucks and uh free returns so uh
go to viore.com Sunny pod and discover
the versatility of viori clothing you're
gonna like it
[Music]
thank you
so now now you guys are off working on
other shows you just came off of Dave
yes just came out for Dave's you were
like doing Dave at the same time yeah it
got a bit crazy
and Dave at the same time yes no one
seemed to consider that uh on the other
end of conversations I wasn't a part of
that maybe there could be some
communication it's the same network
love FX wouldn't work anywhere else yeah
you've been doing Rick and Morty for how
many seasons now uh I've been on it
since middle of season four and we're
writing season nine right now yeah I've
been running the last five seasons or so
yeah I when I heard you were going over
there I was like oh that's good because
you're just so like even cute Xanax
before uh it's worked out well you know
I'm the Whisperer I always forget this
about you because I see I've run into
you your initial kind of like gear is
you're like you're you're in speed one
and you're very close calm and steady
reserved but unlike most people in cars
that go up to like five you have like an
eleven and every now and then we start
to unleash you and ramp you up and when
you get going man oh yeah I feel like I
had to pull you out of a refrigerator at
a convenience store like because I tried
to climb into the back yeah freezer
section I try to climb through where the
beard yeah yeah you got like stuck under
and we had like pulling your legs out
there's a switch
once the switch has been flipped I'm
capable of anything which is exciting
yeah
yeah he doesn't come out as often as he
used to because I'm a dad now and I need
to be shout out to uh Griffin and Reagan
it comes down the writer's room too when
the idea gets cooking right so then like
so we're talking and you and and you're
very analytical and you're talking about
it and then you stumble on something and
then we start pitching something like
that share somewhere you start getting
excited and then you just become
Unleashed which is I think we've piled a
lot of life in I think we've yeah we've
got a ton of stories from you know our
20s and 30s that just were able to pull
from I feel like I've done a lot do you
guys ever feel like I like this
sometimes I'm like I need to stop
working and
do some more living so I have some more
maybe every day I have that thought I
think about that as I'm writing down
writer's perspective it's sort of I
don't know what I'm writing from that is
the hardest one of the hardest things of
uh our very difficult jobs as writers in
Hollywood uh shout out to writers um
just the uh yeah once you find uh some
success and are able to to be working it
can be all-consuming and you aren't
there's no it's all output and no input
yeah that's so much output and you need
to well if we strike let's go out and
live guys yeah and then we can bring it
uh yeah in 2007 when we struck I tried
to get construction jobs because I just
wanted to be with people that I wasn't
working with and they're like no like
they're like flatly rejected this is a
career we know what we're doing you
can't just walk you're gonna die out
here I don't know what's final draft I
ended up getting a job at a at a [__]
pill uh place like a place that sold
colon cleanses ah great was Glenn
ordering why are you sure we don't care
what your experience is I worked at a
sign manufacturing shop and then I
worked at a newspaper in Santa Santa
Monica that you were telling us during
the strike you were uh you were a
restaurant reviewer
I wrote One review yeah yeah I remember
used to call a restaurant from Sunny
used to call la de Jane's and you would
ask them what their soup of the day was
which they would give and then you would
ask them what their smell of the day was
and the person would lose their minds
because you would do it every day to
them and they'll be like God damn it
look at me again like you just hear that
don't call here anymore and your smell
of the day I hear the person go crazy
any uh final thoughts any parting
thoughts when we when we began to
enjoying this show what kind of cell
phone did you guys have was it a flip
phone Nokia a Nokia yeah trying to think
definitely milk yeah I we had to him and
I bought cell phones uh he was in LA
before I was and I landed and neither of
us had cell phones and we couldn't find
each other at the airport yeah it's a
real moment and I I don't remember why
but I feel like I got busted out into uh
I don't even know how I got bust out
into a distant parking lot that you came
off a bus and everyone was calling you
turtle or a made-up name you had but we
couldn't find each other for like two
hours you were terrible but it was
terrible and then the first place we
went was to get cell phones because like
we're like never again that sucked
up to uh
yeah that Juggernaut let's go to the
T-Mobile store have Robin Glenn and I
changed a lot is it different that's a
great question I mean uh
Rob yeah there's been a lot of changes I
would say you have changed the least by
far everyone Remains the Same person and
the same person you're talking to so
that's great Rob is it you know he's
gotten into science he's he's gotten
into companies uh Glenn is on the
Forefront
houses and I still just want to tell
good jokes I just want I just want to
you you're a simple man show up you want
to make him laugh I'm laughing might
want to play a little golf yeah exactly
I want to make a good episode of TV have
we changed no no not at all just older a
little gray but a little grayer blue
gray but uh you've only changed in so
far that I don't get to see you guys as
much as yeah bumps me up yeah I stand on
a kind of a lamentful note let's go find
a little dive bar and like just go nuts
it is the kids not to make it like not
to get too squishy right now but uh
that's like the thing that I miss the
most is the time that we all used to
spend together well this is my point
about
what time well spent just making a thing
we didn't have the kids so maybe there
was a little like time on the side where
we could kind of tool around but
just kind of lost in the weeds and and
and trying to come up with something and
hoping you know people respond to it and
not even really knowing how the speaking
for myself not knowing how I wrote yet
like how do like what are my yeah I mean
you know when it's largely informed by
uh a lot of the you know your
sensibilities and back back at you I
mean I think you guys changed the way I
looked at writing too and thought Oh you
know there's I can go even further into
sort of things that might
appeal to me but
you know don't exist out in the world
and that people will connect with it
Charlie is the fastest script to writers
I mean I think the show succeeded out of
the early Gates because you and Rob had
a special sauce that I don't think you
guys realized you had and that both of
you could go off and write an excellent
scripts like as fast as anyone that I've
worked with and we've worked for a while
now like uh really uh weighs on me how
fast do you guess right me too well I
mean uh I think there's just you know
because it's falling on our shoulders
there's no time to waste like if we
don't get the scripts in there's no one
to blame except us right so I think we
just developed a skill to be like well
just gotta pick an idea and go with it
because there's time is ticking for me
that speed has a lot to do with
um
uh trying to get
out of out of my head
so I rated stream of Consciousness
trying to get into that stream of
conscience trying to tap into that you
know I don't know where it's coming from
get into a flow and just honestly start
just talking as the characters yeah and
that talking
uh just be like okay they're having a
conversation they're saying this that
and the other thing and no me in it like
does whatever the characters saying yeah
how do you guys feel about those sort of
writing books and structures and models
are you like uh well I think it's good
and really useful and you should do it
or you're like I think it's baloney and
I think it for me just speaking
personally it was good to read them and
sort of see different ways that people
are thinking about it and
but then sort of leaving it behind uh as
not using it as like a manual for like
no it has to go like this it's just I'm
a story nerd so I'm into all different
types like it was awesome being at Sunny
forever and just kind of being able to
go for broke and not being really
confined and then we split over to
network with Mick and that was way more
you know buy the book and Rick and Morty
works on the story Circle which is Dan
Harmon's thing and that's it's an
awesome cheat sheet I mean that's the
only way that show goes and it's been
fun in my career just to keep changing
it up in different ways yeah like yeah
like some structure is really invaluable
in terms of just getting the work done
right with sunny we know usually it's 12
scenes so just right yeah they're always
standards one through twelve yeah if we
have that we have an episode I I I've
heard uh David Lynch saying like uh he's
like if you want to write a movie you
know get note cards write 90 or 70
scenes you know each card is a scene
then fill those cards out with what the
scene is then you got a movie
but to some extent that's true you know
then drop all the cards in an order that
doesn't make sense to even yourself yeah
shoot it in that order and the fans will
call it make something indecipherable to
an audience
yeah
yeah get those cards lost in the
weekend I mean I still don't feel like I
know how to break a story and at this
point you do I know that I do but I feel
like I don't it's what I like about it
is like because I'm a story nerd as well
and it puts names on what is actually
instinctual like a story feels like it's
done when it feels satisfying and that's
like an instinct that you have but
knowing why it feels satisfying can
sometimes help you know like what are
the turns what are the inversions what
should some what kind of things should
be happening in the First Act how should
that relate to the end of the second act
those sorts of things where does the dog
melt yeah
where does the cat get lost uh where's
the egg come out but I think like
anything else if you just get so fixated
on it just because it fits the story
structure doesn't mean it's a good story
right yeah well that's writing uh
so uh Scott this is what a podcast is uh
been on a podcast before listening to a
podcast you're the first person ever
that's how I normally operate yeah will
you listen to this
um well you don't have to you live now
why would I certainly wouldn't listen to
myself no yeah yeah well you should
listen to some podcasts here and there
you might you might find well I hear a
lot of good things about this one and
people that are just that just like it I
mean uh you listen to music like when
you work out or uh like uh when are you
listening to anything I feel like I'm
still writing to like thundering techno
that was listening he writes to like the
most aggressive like German techno music
oh dude that's my kid man it's like he's
all just he's like I I listen to his
music um when I drive him to school and
it's all just like
German techno like crazy I used to like
joke on the mick like that Facebook
movie when those programmers are working
like he's wired in like you just hear
thundering techno coming out of
headphones that I'm just writing
takes me to a weird place it's like the
song at the beginning of the movie Blade
I love that smarter sweet spot for
writing good blood rave music yeah there
it is something people would do like
lots of drugs too he's in an office
sober writing you down yeah I guess so
yeah oh man well we've done it we've
done it
this is what it takes that's podcast
podcast there is no writing
and then it just sort of ends and then
it just sort of ends
[Music]
[Applause]